okay hi everyone this is a open language
designer view about data structure which
we introduced what two years ago three
years ago
uh 12.1 so I have a 12 point a few years
ago it's quite quite a few years
two years or three whatever I don't know
some number of years ago okay
let's take a look at the current data
structures
yeah fine so
um well current data structures this is
the list current in 13.3
um so let's talk about who uses them and
for what so I mean I've used them a few
times
basically I have some code
and I realized oh my gosh I can make it
much more efficient by using some known
data structure rather than letting the
system sort of figure that out for
itself
right
right yes that's
I wonder whether Anella lamp would have
a Fighting Chance of figuring out what
kind of data structure some particular
I mean even a piece of code what you
know is could this piece of code be
optimized by using a given data
structure
foreign
I think
I mean
and then okay
so
which of these do you think have been
most popular
I think the
I mean I'm just speaking I think the bit
Vector
um I think the
probably
the you know dynamic array or the or the
extensible vector I think I've used the
hash set before I think
um another one that I think I've used
although this is a bit randoms I've used
I think value
because it's an easy way to basically
make mutable stuff right right
does anybody remember what we used for
that post tag system thing
I don't remember exactly but
um
okay all right so
and other ones were I mean another
question is
sort of there's sort of a connection
between this and things like graph data
structures
this doesn't quite get too graft
well I mean many of these things
represent graphs but they're not
related to our general graph thing the
tree data structure uses a tree you know
the tree
feature uses a tree data structure but
we don't expose that that tree trait
um because they decided to make make
something different it uses it excuse me
it uses it internally so
but so for example converting between
I don't know a linked list
and a in that case trivial graph
is that useful
I mean
I don't think that's especially useful I
mean
one way this maybe could be used well
right so okay
in in graph I think they're like four
different internal representations the
graph uses it can use you know uh list
of edges list of vertices adjacency
Matrix sparse adjacency Matrix and like
like one other something like that right
so you know and in general it's it's you
know it's totally opaque and you don't
usually care
um I mean you could imagine a world
where we sort of have
you know where we're internally graph or
maybe whatever future graph like thing
uh uses you know maybe it has its four
different digital representations each
of those representations is a data
structure that you can call directly
through this but then the outer rapper
is just basically generalizes over those
different data structures if that makes
sense yeah but who cares I mean so long
as we get the automation right to swap
between data structures who cares
I guess I mean in the case of graph the
answer is you never care because I like
I've I don't think I've ever had a
problem with graph quote unquote using
the wrong representation for things like
uh maybe mesh regions which are a lot
more complicated like I think actually
mesh region I think is one but like
Regions they're like 20 different kinds
of regions something like that
um and for that I've definitely run into
things where I'm like oh you're using
the wrong representation
I think there should be a better way to
Hint it than to actually drop down to
the level of data structure operations
yeah yeah I mean it might just be a
matter of you know
have a method option for yeah it might
also be a matter of juristics not being
good enough
but okay so let's look at uh data
structure operations down at the bottom
there
sounds good right right
so they work with this sub-value
mechanism
so you create a data structure and that
pushes you push loads of things
do we like this I mean we invented this
as a
I like it
it's very absolutely crucial because
it's consistent with methods C plus plus
Java rust Julia all the data structures
and also it's a crucial way of being
able to hierarchically represent
one-page structures to another through
another you can get access to say one is
as much as it contains another and then
you can get properties of it and stuff
like that and work with it
a rather than external functions that
apply to the data it's much nicer to add
these to be something I understand but
syntactically
the natural way for us to have done this
would have been verboastly to say you
know data structure operation of uh you
know linked list comma push
that's a function that gets applied to
the data structure rather than to have
the sub-value approach
the sub values are faster than down
values actually I haven't tried exactly
that okay but I did do some experiments
with well we we do care about speed okay
but but like like you you know
stack comma you know that that is
noticeably slower so but but not just
that I mean the method or the data or
the thing is the property of the data
structure is something inherently it
reads the wrong way yeah exactly yeah
something external operating on
something and that's just it's difficult
to organize these things in a nice
hierarchical clean way what I would say
is you know Peak
at the stack it's a function you apply
to the stack
here we've got a sub value of the stack
which I think is weird right we could we
haven't done this but we could have
command completion for these things so
when you you type this and then like now
you get a completion of all that'll be
good we should have completion the
problem is we don't know what DS is well
we we do once it's been evaluated and
sent to the front end we we we we do
know we could tell the front end hey
there's this symbol and this is the
continuations for it well and with the
immutability that might make some sense
I agree yeah yeah I think that would be
pretty pretty neat actually I mean the
mutability is another key thing about
these so that's like absolutely breaking
them all yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah right
but I mean look that would certainly
help
yeah yeah
I mean that's a okay so bring that up
with the front-end team but I mean Mark
you're actually arguing that you like
the sub-value organization better than
you would like functions absolutely
finally so much
when you work anything you do in another
language and you take a date instructors
course in something else and the way
that they're all set up and
uh there's a reason why they're built up
in this kind of way this kind of
object-centric way that you can get
methods and data and all these kinds of
things because
It just fits into the Paradigm that's
using other types of languages so
naturally and I think that's well I
think it's quite important for these
things I mean another key point is you
don't have to worry what context these
these methods are in you see now for the
core ones in the Wolfram language yeah
that's fine but when we write tons of
these things internally in the compiler
and it would be unusable if we had to
they were all in different contexts in
different packages yeah yeah yeah yeah
symbols and context that is one of the
main problems with all this structuring
it in a kind of nice clean way whereas
here it's just you can have a look up
you've got a limited number of special
of of data structures here just like we
have special functions no no but I'm
talking in other places like in the same
things work inside the compiler I mean
it's nice to have the same programming
model and as we're compiling the
compiler we use the same techniques so
we get like a win you know a win in
compiling the compiler is winning for
you know in in driving the language and
also it's useful because somebody writes
something it interactively like this
will use the same syntax internally when
these are working on the compiled eggs
instructors identical and I think that's
important not to have two syntaxes one
one for top level or a sort of an
evaluator sort of model of the data
structure and one for the compile the
only thing that's different is the
Constructor is like data structure
backtick new or whatever instead of
create data structure as you but the
rest data structure as well yeah the
rest of the operations are identical and
I think that's quite important yeah to
make it kind of
wow okay
well by the way Daniel on a live stream
is asking all those structures
implemented in wolfen language run C the
answer is they're implemented with a
compiler right yes yes so they are
written The Source language is worth
language but it is compiled into llbm
and they're pretty Mark you you're
you're a hard you know they're pretty
they
you know we've been polishing them but
they they work pretty well actually I
mean yeah they work quite efficiently
stuff in the compiler is faster than the
kernel one now so um yeah I mean they're
pretty competitive with you know C plus
plus well okay so one of my purposes in
this meeting was discuss the sub-value
mechanism the
and you guys are vehemently insisting
that sub values are the right way to go
we sorry but yes
I really like it yeah that's good we've
also done the sub value things for some
other you know and these are more you
know some more and some less documented
but but two examples I can think of are
interpolating function and
and sparse array we have some I know
which uh I mean we have sub values for
lots of other functions but they don't
the difference is sub values don't
usually do operations sub values you
know extract properties of things that's
pretty common well that's just gonna be
doing a mutable stuff elsewhere
good point yeah
okay
well okay I mean all right so then let's
let's talk I mean
people about getting continuation things
I mean if I have to add stuff to the
kernel to do that I'll I'll I'll do that
right okay so let's then look at let me
let me poke around at um these data
structures let me ask some questions
okay fine
one question is what about user
interface data structures
does that make any sense
to have something in this framework
that is a raw you know some raw user
interface construct because I mean
obviously in you know in the libraries
that we use to build notebooks and all
that kind of thing
there's endless data structures that
represent you know window on the screen
and stuff like this
doesn't make any sense to give access to
those things
I mean we could build it might be
disjoint from the front end the front
you know we could build access to sort
of you know various libraries that do
this the front end could expose data
structures that could be manipulated in
this way I don't know if they want to do
that but but they could the front end
could use some of these things as well
if if they wanted to I mean the other
thing about these data structures they
all have serializations
um you know I know I remember fighting
sterilizations we put a lot of work into
making these work work nicely and then
make them work faster you know so that's
by the way are the serializations binary
or the serializations input form
serializations are full form type of
things but they might include things
like byte arrays and things like that
but you could probably have a binary
account yeah you don't but but some of
them do bit back to does so okay but but
one thing you could imagine what happens
if you feed the data structure out to
wxf
it will get converted it will it will
get serialized
into full form and then the wxf will
pick up that full form and then when it
comes back it'll be deserialized
is it efficient
um it it I mean
it's all to n so if you have a
billionaire I understand that but it
probably depends on the data structure
yeah I mean it might get like unpacked
you might have a bit representation that
gets unpacked or bite records might be
big
and up split so I mean that's one
possibility is whether there's a sense
in which there is direct serialization
to wxf from compiled stuff
that's that's an interesting idea I've
never built a wxf interface direct from
the compiler but I've often thought you
probably should so and then then we'll
take an expression data structure go
ahead when I I know there was a way to
do that like I thought wxf I didn't know
there was a way of extending it because
it's like
what about Chris Cooley's stuff but the
the expression what is that thing the
expression
do you know what I'm talking about
Crystal you know what I'm talking about
yeah you mean the the Standalone apps
the the um the expression interface yeah
yeah isn't that a binary interface to
expressions
um not in the same way I mean that
that's about that's about having uh you
know exposing the extra struct to C
I see
okay but so so the idea that there might
be something which could take and a
thing
that is one of these data structures
I just have a dangling array of sort of
bits in the data structures it actually
has a you know we've tried to make it
yeah yeah that will get serialized out
nicely if it's a numerical rail get
serialized out nicely
has the support of yeah it already has
the support of that uh of that for the
America ray types and stuff like that so
so some of them not all of them I mean
like a tree or something there's no
direct thing with the pointers and
everything to do everything
why isn't there something like an MX
file that is the memory image
essentially of that tree
well I don't know about that you start
getting into all sorts of things like
Indian and Stephen I mean already the
serialization of these things is I mean
it takes us long to write the
serialization for data structure as
writing the code for the data structure
itself so already that is well equipment
I'm asking is there a generic way to do
this given how it's laid out in memory
and when we solve the end in this
problem in the end for MX files how do
we solve the end in this problem uh at
least a lot of work to just you know
write out bytes
and in an independent way and check what
the platform is and then bite swap them
and stuff like that and she was like a
month or two work okay but but
automatically
but about about automatically
serializing I mean I think it seems like
right if we could
so um most data structures are basically
product types containing other data
structures
so in that you know and integers and
stuff like that that we can serialize so
in that sense it probably is possible to
automatically serialize a lot of them
um
you know there's some base ones that are
harder because they have pointers and
stuff like that
but but I think that the ones that are
easy to automatically serialize are
probably also easy to write the
serialization code yourself
yeah I I I also I don't think the
serialization should reflect the low
levels yeah absolutely because then we
can't optimize that locks us into a
low-level storage which we might not
exactly let me ask this question with
the next files I've got 100 megabyte
data structure okay I want to serialize
it am I going to end up with 10
gigabytes of crud or am I going to end
up with something reasonably small
why don't you look at an actual full
form
well I mean
let's let's come and do
well that's that's oh there's one right
there yeah I mean there's the one for
the stack there although the stack is a
little bit uninteresting push a million
zeros onto a stack
right okay
[Music]
zero
right okay
that was spectacularly fast
prove to me that it has a million zeros
on it can you how is there a stacked
depth
yes
I mean these things are the the speed of
C Steve I mean you could do okay I
understand now I want to see that 10
million 10 million to 100 million
operations
let's see how big is this thing well if
we say byte count of DS yeah actually
bite count is not
good lie yeah that's that's not true
it's only implemented for about half the
data we've been we've been filling in
bytes yeah I've done half disabled some
of the filters
realize just do length of binary
serialize
or actually you don't even need the
length because the the summary box will
say it in a nicer way so yeah I've never
done this
and this will tell us the size of the
full form right
two megabytes that's not bad
wait how's that even possible
that means spending two bytes per D
serialized
okay yeah
and a logical length of that
okay
hang on
ah crap sorry
I mean you could even just say or I
don't know if same Q works yeah yeah
let's do it does seem to work let's try
it yeah yeah
we put how did it managers get oh wait a
second how is it two megabytes
so if you look at the full form of it my
guess is that WX Seth is
storing the integers in some
sort of
small way yeah it might be run length
encoded or something I don't know maybe
one more experiment could you do that do
with a random integer there right yeah
yeah random integer there
random integer of of of of 10 to the six
like that that's right yep
actually that's now going to add to the
same stack right fine yes let's do it
okay so now do binary serialize or
whatever okay all right I did just check
so so wxf uses Varin so integers are
only the number of bytes that they need
to be plus one
well okay five megabytes the
is so that's five bytes per integer
which is very respectable
right that's that's very reasonable it's
not terrible now dude binary serialize
with that
it's interesting that binary D serialize
seems to be a lot slower than just
constructing it from scratch
yes well this is very respectable I mean
it's not embarrassing right yeah
no these are good but now
why aren't we using binary serialize
when you store this thing out to a file
I often use wxf
I mean it depends on how you want which
is right binary serializes producing wxf
yeah I did some experience with this
like a little bit ago about wxf versus
MX and I remember that they were very
similar but for deeply nested things wxf
did significantly better and there was
one case where MX did significantly
better I don't remember exactly what
okay all right let's go back to the
razors okay this is great I mean this is
good let's come back to data structures
the list of data structures and let's
just talk a little bit about what okay
so another question is the
visualizations of these data structures
which we sort of Hope will be useful for
educational purposes has that panned out
we use it
in what way well like when we're
building them we look oh wait when you
add add and delete elements from things
you want to see if your visualization is
filling up with things in the right
place or whether it's you've got
something aligned wrong or or you know
doing the right thing what's up
my next question is if I looked at you
know the textbook list of data
structures
what data structures would I find in the
textbook that I don't find here
so I think um actually we we have this
it didn't quite make it in 133 but a new
balanced binary tree are better so we
have AVL treatment we have a better one
which is a red black tree which is much
more standard and with that there's a
whole ton of other data structures that
we can build on top of it but like what
which which are for sorting searching
type stuff
so yeah that sort of thing for him what
was you you came up with tons of
interesting things what were some of the
things you were coming up with
one of them was that
uh sorted set would be one of them yeah
no there were other things as well oh
the Rope data structure which is used
the Rope thing that was it that was
interesting yes that is what internally
text editors use
for implementing yeah text editors where
you have
[Music]
so
if I go to
a friendly
chat CPT for example what's that right
this is the Rope thing so it it is kind
of a it's pretty interesting actually so
okay well that's fine but that's the
thing I I never heard of it I'm I'm glad
to learn about it but that's um
and the thing is once you have a really
good
red black tree implementing this is very
easy you see that's that's the other
nice thing is you get you get these
things for free Okay so let's just I
just asked our friendly llm you know
list some commonly used data structures
it said arrays okay we got those linked
lists Stacks cues what do we have in
queues
priority we got cues priority queue well
property is more a hacks
well a priority queue is is a heat ready
so
okay
um all right so if we go
I mean have we done this exercise of
just going and looking for
sort of other I mean there are you know
in in like computational geometry there
are tons of data structures right
which we don't have here
not not all but we've been adding like
when we never anybody asks for something
we if if it's feasible we we we we add
it so that's
yeah like the KD tree was added because
some other computations yes
okay but like you know you look at some
random Source like Wikipedia for example
and you'll see all kinds of I mean
there's there's several Pages you just
say a list of data structures to say
list of data structures
by the way I hope that our data
structures make it onto these pages in
Wikipedia where when we have a version
of it with visualizations and so on
yeah separate issue okay but but um
what is a
multi-map for example
um well it's um it's a like a hash table
but where there are you can have the
same key can appear more than once
okay sets but not not multi
um okay scroll down here let's just see
what other things uh
all kinds of random stuff here which
I've never heard of mostly circular
buffers do we have one of those you have
a ring buffer I think I think that's
what yeah I hope we just have the
keyword circular buffer to go along I
would need to check that but I'll I'll
make I will check that
exactly okay another question is in the
scroll down here a bit yeah sure
I mean many of these things we either
have or don't have I don't know
I think a lot of this is kind of a
uh
so one one type of data structure I
think we should have more of a more
immutable ones and we've been we have
one immutable one
um
but but I'd like to have more of those I
think those are kind of interesting and
they kind of fit obviously quite well
into the expression sort of notion so
what's an example of an unusual data
structure well um Association is an
immutable data structure
fine but why do we need that in the data
structure system we already have that in
the main system we don't have for
example a set version of it no we don't
that will be used that would be useful
right yeah
that would be useful yeah let's go
scroll down so that that one to me is
seems like a decent priority and one
that could be promoted out of the pure
like tree was promoted out of the pure
data structure world yes yeah I I think
that's true it's quite hard actually
that's to make a nice one so but for him
has been working on that but it's it's
quite hard there's um I think immutable
trees like like an immutable balanced
binary tree would be kind of interesting
I think so
well I mean okay scroll down here I mean
many of these are just sort of
amusing but who cares yeah
spqr tree
scroll down is there anything else here
let's go down
asts abstract syntax trees that's a
that's a place where we might
yeah that's interesting I mean you have
the extra struct so that's a bit like
that but we don't have no that's that's
interesting I think that will be an
interesting one and useful
foreign
so we've got you know representatives of
the you've got
yeah which may be enough you've got a
very good the cooking filter we Mark's
just
totally
okay scroll down
things like scene grass okay so
hypergraph by the way uh Nick has been
implementing in one of our Institute
projects has been implementing a bunch
of hypergraph related stuff I don't know
whether he's been using data structures
I I he hasn't talked to me if if if he
has but no I think somebody should ping
him and find out if he is right because
he's built a whole elaborate thing for
doing okay so here's another category of
data structure okay is
things I think we can leave this page I
guess
I think we're we're I think we're at the
end right yes I can
I can
go back to uh
okay whatever okay so
you know that typograph thing that would
be useful so can somebody here please
ping next I've made a note of that oh
well okay yeah
okay
um
now abstract look here's an interesting
category okay including other work that
Nick was doing on pattern matching
representations
I wonder if there are other things which
are more
like the expression data structure
the things that are more sort of innards
of our system you know partial
representations of pattern matching
things like this
that's interesting
where
you know there are internal things in
our system that could be exposed
usefully
um
I mean the abstract syntax tree will be
an example
you know it seems like what is the
output of the parser
an expression
but
yeah okay fair enough but what is it I
mean I I sorry I'm not trying to be
flippant but no no you're right you're
right I mean is there a previous stage
even the Alexa what's the output of the
Lexa
it's like bolted into the parser for
efficiency reasons if we want to oh but
hang on what you're asking is feasible
and in the old days
of of Brenton Brenton and I were talking
about representing his pars trees as a
data structure and that that would be
not not so you know that would interface
into his C plus code now Connor's
Rewritten it I think as rust but it that
that could be done to have a data
structure view into you know those
structures might be interesting that
seems useful because I mean we want to
manipulate code yeah yeah that's the
question of how do we do that and I mean
the the Expo struct is way too kind of
digested to a semantic level it's
completely it's totally correct what it
is it's a viewing to our expression so
that's yeah right but okay so let's ask
this question
let me ask a few more questions about
other things that are sort of partial
pieces of our system like I don't know
sparse arrays is there some intermediate
representation there that will be useful
to be able to get one's hands directly
onto Rob sure there is a sponsor a type
that so the sparse array so so one of
the things I did was first read to make
it work with the compiler is I set up a
very data structure like thing
um with the sparse array but it doesn't
quite fit into this framework because
because there are different different
underlying types like you know so for
example we could probably compress the
graph representation as a sparse array
by using you know unsigned integer 8
type sparse arrays instead of the
machine integer types that we're using
right now
okay so the issue that we have is that
the data structure data structure the
symbol
deals with unparametrized data
structures like as far as data structure
is concerned it's a linked list of
Expressions right so exactly where they
are polymer not all of them are you know
like like a bit Vector isn't polymorphic
it's just yeah
but um where they're polymorphic what we
instantiate is ones for
um Expressions which which is great but
we could consider some mechanism of
instantiating other ones you know
specialized for machine integers or
something but how would that work
doesn't the compiler already have that
notion in a you know the type specifiers
yeah the right compiled code you do but
yeah you'd need to build a library or
something like that you need to write
some compiled code and I'm working on
I'll just mention I'm working on it has
some very interesting things yes yeah so
so I'm working at so for this tabular
project I'm working on an underlying
data structure so it's the idea of the
tablers are going to represent data in a
column wise fashion because typically
columns are consistently typed so so my
basic data structure for theirs I mean
I'm calling it it's I'm actually setting
up as a data structure but it's it is
type parameterizing I'm calling it for
right now a data Vector that may not be
the right name but it could have type
the element type could be string or the
element type
expression and so on and that allows us
to have sort of a uniform structure for
these things of different types and and
that's working out I mean you know I
think it's going to be very efficient
right I mean there's the other thing Rob
we were talking about which was the
string the string vector or string array
string string yeah I call it string list
or something so the key point is that
these data structures as you have them
here there's sort of still a you know
this is an application of the compiler
where what's inside these data
structures is Expressions the question
is if you want to go the next level of
having one of these data structures but
having what's inside it be you know
8-bit integers or something correct how
would you do that
well you could write compile code and
minor and use the compiler but the
question is can you do the same thing
that we're doing with the data
structures where there is no compiler
invisible well we would have to
instantiate it these only exist because
they are pre-built
y but so what we could in principle
imagine doing is saying
but I mean wouldn't it be okay we could
we could pre-build a bunch of obvious I
don't know binary trees with uh with
integers on the nodes
and then if you want a binary tree with
some weird struct on the nodes why
couldn't you Auto build it at the time
when you define it you you could do it
it
takes a bit of time you know it might
take a long time yeah it takes time A
long time yeah so okay the problem is
that the compilation of that but if if
okay
and it could be in a wfr so what would
happen if there was a you know a data
structure is it consumable that there
should be a data structure Repository
that's an interesting idea I think um
it's still a bit specialized to build
these things is my answer so
yeah but so there's also there's also
another issue because like with the
compiler uh you can compile it locally
to your machine and it will use the best
instruction set that you have but if you
put it into a function repository you'd
have to dumb it down like we do when we
ship Mathematica we dump it down to the
lowest x86 version we're willing to
support whatever so so you'd put you
push
some sort of version that's not quite so
optimized that yeah okay like bit Vector
that's the real thing yeah I mean the
other thing is that you see the
instructions and stuff Steven that is a
factor of four or more inefficiency I
mean it's not to throw away okay
Library optimized for your machine that
would be an interesting thing that that
would be useful
well okay I mean then that's a but that
requires a different Plumbing I mean
look it took a lot of effort to get to
the point where it compiled function is
transportable which it now is correct
yes
I mean within the same platform it it's
pretty fast I mean Christopher keeps
heading yeah it's it is yes but I mean
it works you can make a wfr with
compiled code and it's transportable
correct
yes yes that's that's that's true right
but how much are we losing when we do
that I mean Mark you were speed demoning
this and claiming a factor of four are
we losing that when we make it
transportable in that way yeah
we're making a generic version yeah
because you'll build for a generic
platform so I mean these things these
things you'll see with with low level
arithmetic bit operations you know stuff
that can be relevant for all the
optimized exactly I mean some some of
you might notice it a lot less but I
know with it because I work on
arithmetic stuff I know but but other
people might not notice it so okay I'm
just pointing out it's an issue okay
there would I mean let's throw away that
is too for a second and ask the question
what I mean parameterized data
structures
which
you know where we could store
yeah I mean okay so look there's some
additional Plumbing needed if we're
going to do
so these are non-parameterized data
structures basically there's a
parameterized for expression
I get it right so they are they are
parameterized
yeah I mean look that stack example was
very impressive that was very nice and
optimized
um let me ask one more question here so
this is relevant to Christopher's ffi
stuff and so on
if we were to use data structures that
come from external libraries
and were to kind of merge them into this
concept
would that make any sense
we could yes well except you know if
we're using Expressions it wouldn't be
so totally trivial and it probably
wouldn't it might not work quite as well
our compiler is very optimized to work
with Expressions no I understand that
but I mean let's say you're using some
GIS data structure or something well
sure yeah well we we do that we have
like this GEOS thing that uh right but
okay but the thing the thing is is that
right I mean
as we talked about earlier there are
several properties the data structures
you know have in addition to just being
blocks of memory I mean they're
serializable they're they're portable
you know Etc
this is not true for a generic thing you
get from a library and in fact a generic
thing you get from a library you know
it's either a number or it's a pointer
so I mean right now we represent things
as numbers or pointers when they come
from the ffi
adding it's a fine you know
okay
yeah the things that come from the ffi
are not of the same sort I won't say
type
as
the things well they often are but we
don't know nearly as much right I mean
we're just you know you're given very
little you're given a pointer which is
basically a number yeah and you don't
know how it's memory managed you don't
know what methods it supports or how to
call them you don't know anything okay
you're gonna have to make that yourself
but if you could get
things from the from ffis into the data
structure World other things that are
very juicy
I just don't know what this would mean I
mean it would just be a matter of of
supporting kind of the syntax that that
data structure does of like I mean
to use a compiler interface than an ffi
interface I think as well
okay there's some overhead to the ffi
maybe not very measurable in the
evaluator but we should probably wrap up
here but but we've got a couple of
questions from this live stream towards
us asking are data structure size is
limited by Machine integers
yes but that's 64-bit integers so that's
not what do you think yeah right so you
you will not be able to get enough
memory to blow it up no you'll never be
able to on a 64-bit machine you'll never
be able to uh
I mean I mean that's that's like
exabytes isn't it yeah I don't have to I
don't have that much memory actually
some of these platforms like arm
platforms they're used to higher order
bits for
um you know sort of encrypt you know for
Value security purposes so
so they're blown up 62 of the 64 bits or
something they've taken a few of the
higher order bits and they've got check
sums and things in for security
uh there's a question from valued here
any plans to integrate data structure
more directly with the rest of language
EG
are
total of DS if DS is a stack of integers
I think we made this decision well we do
have well we do have iterators over data
structures so you could write total or
other operations as things that iterate
through the days yeah the question is
the questions being asked is
if I simply said total of DS does it
work no at the moment no but it's
implementable if it was written as an
iterator if total had an iterator method
that would just be independent of the
data structure something that would just
say start at the beginning and iterate
through right then it would work for all
data structures so so because it's
polymorphic it will be done in a way
that I can have a fold operation so
which is pretty pretty that that's a
nice access nice functional access
what if we somebody asks for you know
determinant or something right right
good question right Norm would be a
better example or
for a down code font I mean things like
total that have down code or stuff then
then every every extra thing we add we
have to put an if is it this data
structure and then we have to check to
make sure it's compatible but we
wouldn't do it that way we would do it
generically is it a data structure okay
then you know use an iterator
yeah that that would be fine we would
probably use both
right so the question is what functions
is there a set of functions I mean look
throughout the system
we make it be the case that typing you
know
some obvious function
eats some other obvious function
so the question is for these data
structures
I mean like if you say total of for
example a bit Vector what on Earth would
that mean
yeah God knows
and it starts being a you know a pun or
an analogy type thing of what's this
supposed to mean
I mean in the case of total and stack
it's fairly obvious right
right I mean I think in general
the outside functions are kind of you
know
like
I think the sub values are really the
thing to use the fact that any functions
work on the outside other than maybe
full foreign the fact that like length
works I think is you know it's a nice
little convenience but it you know you
shouldn't rely yeah it's very
questionable because I don't know what
the hell length means for a tree
number of elements right
well that's not totally obvious to me
yeah no that's not obvious but it's it's
not crazy
right so that's why it's much better
just to have the data structure specific
property that's either you know Leaf
count or something or if it's called
length at least you know that springy of
length isn't doesn't necessarily have
anything to do with bit vector or blank
right
I think we need to transition to a
different meeting which is also going to
be live streamed it's part of our LD
series but I think the main conclusion
here is that it would be nice if we
could promote these more I don't think
they get used enough because they're
very nice
well
random people in the company that you
know come to me and say oh I love that
you know this I use it all the time and
it's so but anyway well okay that's a
different the marketing of data
structures is a different issue
now that they work what's that not
irrelevant
see yeah so yes or maybe somebody should
write a little book book about you know
data structures that uses these data
structures and shows people the nice
pictures and so on
yep yep yep that sounds or at least I
mean I don't even know what the data
structure guide page looks like you
bring it up
does it is it attractive
uh well let's look at the listing of
data structures
oh they'll just just go right here we go
here's the guide page
I mean it's functional
yeah it's okay
I think I mean what will be a way to
promote this
uh one thing would be if our code
assistant system if the llm-based code
assistant system knows about the stuff
that will be one really good way to
promote it yeah yeah
in general if we have a
essentially llm Persona that's all about
optimizing code
and it has a Fighting Chance of
suggesting have you considered using a
doubly linked list or something I don't
know whether it does so Fighting Chance
for figuring that out yeah how would you
go if you're presented with a piece of
Orphan language code
and like my example those tag systems
okay
what does it take to be able to figure
out here's a reasonable data structure
to use
yeah I mean that that's a good question
I can look at it and I can see oh you're
doing this and that and in a sense
that's how an llm Works isn't it I mean
it's
more or less yes I mean the question is
could we ask you can see it why why
can't the LL
but I have some years of experience of
like data strategists and more from
language
right now I mean I'm just wondering if
there's a sample we could just ask the
llm right now whether it could um let me
think I mean this piece of code well
actually we could give it the tag system
give it the code for a tag system and
see what it can do
um I I'd be amazed if I could do this
because I think I think that we're
um
uh
when does it make sense to use a ring
buffer I can ask it
you want to share No actually because
I'm not I don't have it set up correctly
for that
um I'm just gonna I'm just gonna try
this just for fun
um I'm asking gpt4
a ring buffer also known as a circular
buffer a circular queue makes sense in
situations where fixed size storage
fixed amount of memory you need to
manage it without allocating money okay
so this is much more conceptual yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's not code right
overwriting old data blah blah blah I
mean this is fine but
it's like what does it take this is
really the question what does it take to
look at a piece of code like like for
example if we looked at our internal
code the thing that we've long wanted to
do okay here's a challenge
is there a way of scanning our internal
code
and predicting
where we might insert a data structure
I mean maybe you know if you see a pen
to in in a loop so I mean okay so that's
it that's a that's a clue so that will
be an interesting exercise just Nano
internal code and look for a pentus yeah
yeah
that's a good thing to try doing
[Music]
and what are some other Clues I mean
basically it's whenever One is using
sort of small-scale mutability
yeah
that's that's one of them yes
so okay when there's mutability
I mean so
I mean there's other things when you're
using like set operations it may be that
the hash set which is blindingly fast
and mutable is quite good as well
right well there are places where you're
generating a whole giant expression
and you probably want something more
mutable yeah yeah
but let's see if we can figure out what
some of those criteria are maybe an Alum
can find them for us or maybe if we're
still continuing our rule-based code
assistance we could use those or comment
combination where we prompt the llm with
the rules
all right I think we have to wrap up
here but that was useful and I think
there's
you know fundamentally it seems like
there's no major change here and this
good stuff yeah
all right well and I think the promotion
is
you know whenever I mean look here's the
thing we could do we could generate
you know we're not yet doing this but I
mean we could generate
you know the whole idea of code
assistance was to generate default
advisory messages for code
and so when we see append to
it's reasonable to Guess that there's a
sort of default advisory message that we
can generate
that says consider using data structures
okay anyway we should wrap up here
thanks guys see you later